imagine growing up in Baghdad and seeing
your brother and cousin killed by Al
Qaeda and other sectarian forces imagine
getting death threats from radical
groups such as the Mahdi army a
religious militia that once controlled
large parts of us occupied Iraq that's
some of what 27 year-old Faisal Saeed Al
Matar faced during his childhood growing
up in Baghdad in Iraq born into a family
that prized analytical thinking he wrote
critically of Islam and lived a secular
lifestyle making him a target for
radical groups Matar fled to the United
States five years ago here he heads up
ideas Beyond Borders a nonprofit that
promotes freedom of expression enough
for eteri countries al Qaeda took over
my neighborhood I mean they almost took
over my neighborhood like I wake up
every morning and there are dead bodies
on the streets and beheadings i sat down
with Muhtar to talk about his life his
experience with radical Islam and ideas
Beyond Borders latest project which is
to translate into Arabic works by
secular enlightenment thinkers such as
Harvard psychologist Steven Pinker and
then distribute them for free to readers
in North Africa and the Middle East
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason today
we're talking with Faisal Saeed Al Matar
he's the head of ideas Beyond Borders
and we're gonna talk to him about that
organization and its aims in the Arab
Muslim Middle East Faisal thanks for
talking thanks for having me ideas
Beyond Borders what is it it's a
nonprofit organization global nonprofit
organization focused on preventing
extremism before it takes root it's come
from my personal experience as well as
my professional experience is that most
of the war on terror and now we're
September's has been 17 years since that
happened have always been dealing with a
deal of the tip of the iceberg killing
the bin Laden's killing the Isis's but
nobody has really been engaging that
much with really how to prevent it from
really escalating to radicalization and
terrorism and I grew up in Iraq and I
know for a fact that Isis al Qaeda did
not come out of nowhere it came from a
result of really bad education and a
little lack of information and mass
ignorance so the established
organization to actually not to sell it
to convert people but to expose the Arab
you
a diverse set of knowledge one of the
main projects that you're doing is you
translate books into Arabic yes we do
our circulation into the Middle East the
Arab world the Muslim world yes what are
the types of books that you're you know
that you're translating so obviously
very selective about the type of books
the category that we are that we have
put is the books that really open up the
mind that that stimulates curiosity
makes people really wonder that there is
something out there other than we're
constantly exposed to the main I would
say the main focus is exposed Arab world
enlightenment values the values that
really has created that progress what we
see in the world the main one book we're
translating is a Latin man now by Steven
Pinker who sees an advisory board who
was kind of mean kinda back home like
the Ayatollah of ibv he's like the the
spiritual Ayatollah is not is that the
Khomeini but moral Sistani version so
he's being kind of the the guiding
principle at least his some of his
values are guiding principle and so on
so like I became thankful he gave us the
right to oh pretty much all his books
several authors like sam harris Maajid
Nawaz have also giving us access to most
of their books and can I ask is the core
idea that has to sink into the Arab
world or the Middle East or the Muslim
world you know of extremists yeah is the
idea of secular government or what what
is what is so key about the Western
enlightenment hitting at that part of
the world I mean the intersection of
religion and politics have been really a
major problem since millennia since I
mean the enabled Ottoman Empire they
tried to make the loegen government and
then the regimes afterwards so I would
say secularism is a major component also
the concept of critical thinking is not
really common because all of these
ideologies and also of the terrain
governments don't want these governments
that don't want the people to think for
themselves so I would put secularism as
well as critical thinking and the
ability to really question authority
whatever that authority is I would say
is a central component that we want to
bring to the Muslim world because at the
moment the people are able to think for
themselves the moment all of these
brainwashing and all of this dogma that
they are being taught all the time will
be questioned
and that's gonna lose many of its value
we tend to look at the tip of the
iceberg the actual Islamic terrorism or
our extremists but there's this in you
know it's built up on an education
system that is that is weak where is
that education system coming from and
how long has it been in place if you
look at it as a kind of a spectrum you
put let's say ten being the Isis's of
the world as well as of the world there
is so people move gradually sometimes
quickly from the stage zero being kind
of the cultural open-minded Muslim to
the tens so I grew up in the in the in
the education system of Saddam Hussein's
Iraq and then many of the Syrians are
growing up and Rashad and then the ones
in Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia grew and
there's a kind of the Wahhabi and then
Egypt is also under CC / Azhar / Muslim
Brotherhood this is this is a mainstream
like bad education that most of the arab
youth are getting its their leaves no
room whatsoever for any room for
critical thinking and that's why I like
when whenever there are so many polls
are done I mean for example you hear
like so many people having contradictory
beliefs one of the I mean it's not
obviously the most accurate one but they
ask people like do you believe Islam
origin of peace they said yes like 70
percent people said yes and that's our
Muslim audiences then they said do you
think people should be killed for living
Islam many of the same people who say
this limitation of peace said yes the
people who live Islam should be killed
and and and that contradiction is not
coming out of no one in my opinion from
really lack of being able to maintain
reason and the same thing for for like
questions about 9/11 and jihadism and
all of these questions I was like do you
believe 9/11 is a good idea no I don't
believe but do you believe the suicide
bombing and killing civilians is okay if
you have a bigger goal they probably
he's gonna say yes so there's like this
contradictory of the mind is is is
ingrained because of many of these
dictatorships and extremists really want
to keep the people as ignorant as
possible and and they have failed to
some extent when the arc Spring happened
I mean the Arab Spring was kind of the
beginning of people saying stop it stop
it not necessarily I mean there are so
many reasons whether
happen we can discuss for a long time
but some of it is that we are not going
to be listening to everything you're
telling us to be true and that is and
has been done successfully in countries
like Tunisia in which many of the people
are educated I've been exposed to
enlightenment values because of the
relationship with the France and the
goal is to really take that Tunisian
experiment of education that's why the
Arab Spring is one more successful than
any other Arab Spring like Tunisia
because the education the population is
educated and they have been exposed to
these ideas of separation of powers
secularism the importance of individual
rights all of these things so even when
they had a protest it was less violent
it was about values it was what people
really wanted their rights but if you
look at the other parts of the region
like Syria like like Egypt because the
men of the people were ignorant because
of the regimes you see that even
revolutions were not there were some of
them were violent they took a path of
violence and they were not really
motivated that much by the ideals of
French Revolution which is how sometimes
talk about how difficult it is to
distribute these texts I mean this is a
great thing if you you know you get
Steven Pinker donates the right to the
arab translation of enlightenment hour
of his previous books how difficult is
it to take that book and you turn it
into an electronic form yeah and you
circulate it talk about the difficulties
in that the process that we acquire the
rights legally and then we translate
them and then we added them and
proofread them and then make them
available as PDF and also we're
expanding to the audiovisual and go to
audiobook and others in terms of reach I
mean the Middle East mostly have access
to social media with terms and
conditions apply because sometimes you
get monitored and everything and but now
I would say one of many of the things
that I love about the region is that
many of the is one of the youthful most
youthful populations in the world and
they have this tech savviness in which
if the government is blocking this
website they know how to install a VPN
etc etc so we have multiple distribution
partners in which they have we're pretty
much access to roughly between 30 to 40
million
people between the ages of 15 and 30 and
these are social media pages with and
and and social media is actually playing
a major role in while it's a source for
faking news for many parts of the West
but it's also a source of really
spreading good ideas because that's not
the the mainstream so baby we will go to
the social media for the alternative
sources and and we're trying to make
this alternative soldiers to be a Latin
man now so we package the book and we
make it as accessible as possible easy
to click and building our digital
library is gonna be done in three months
named after the House of Wisdom in
Baghdad so that's kind of to give it a
cultural connotation and I would say I
mean other than I mean there are some
countries who are much more difficult I
mean Saudi Arabia I would say they the
theory of evolution the Wikipedia page
of theory of evolution is banned in
Saudi Arabia one of the issues also
we're currently facing is that many of
the translators who work in the region
mostly those who work in a more
established translation houses because
there are blasphemy laws inside these
countries they cannot deal with this
they're like if we if we translated
Latin men now and blasphemy can mean
literally anything you want to be I mean
the Emir of Dubai if he thinks that
condoms are a blasphemous means
blasphemous so it's not necessarily a
very specific definition so one of the
issues were Cole was facing is that the
publishing houses as well as a
translation house in the region were
like we don't want to touch this
material this is big and that's reason
why we exist to be honest this is
actually because we became the publisher
considering we are based in the United
States so we're not ruled by I mean
thanks thanks to Allah right we don't
have we're not ruled by blasphemy laws
and all of that so we're kind of
utilizing the First Amendment's in their
States so that's why it's gonna give us
a great ability to operate freely and
then we publish this material online and
make people access them from there how
much of the problem is an Arab problem
and how much of it is a Muslim problem
is the fundamental issue with Islamic
radicalism rooted in the Middle East
Islam originated from the Middle East
and what I think really well I think
what really makes the Middle East
important I think in the most important
is because the countries that
have happened to have the most extremist
ideologies happen to have the most oil
resources and national gas so while in
Indonesia is important and so is
Malaysia and South Pakistan and
Bangladesh in fact there are more
Muslims in South Asia than in the Middle
East but we make the most trouble and
the reason why we make the most of all
is that even if even though Islam is
coming from there but also their kind of
the more radical ideas like Salafism and
Wahhabism etc and with the help of oil
resources and natural gas it was able to
spread its way to every way you're
talking about Saudi Arabia
mainly Saudi Arabia and Qatar to start
extent would like the Muslim Brotherhood
an Islamist material so I mean these are
countries on the top list of natural gas
and oil and and and there has been lot
of geopolitics and in the war against
the Soviet Union and all of that that
they have became a major player and
other parts of the world so I think that
if we really want to get rid of radical
radical ism in general we really have to
start with the Middle East because I
think the South Asian radicalization is
the tip of the iceberg of the Middle
East of radicalization so if and and
I've been optimistic but also not
optimistic about kind of the rise of MBS
and in Saudi Arabia but I mean moving
country from the 622 8th century is not
liberalisation materials but I think
it's still better than nothing so if
there was reform towards more human
humanistic or universal human rights
approach I think it will have an effect
on the total totality of the Muslim
world the 1.5 billion will be affected a
plus like I mean Mecca is where most
Muslims go for Hajj I mean
many Muslims will have to be exposed to
the Middle East in one or another they
have to go to do the pilgrimage there if
they're not gonna do if they're Shias
they're mostly gonna go to najaf and
karbala in iraq so they're gonna come to
the Middle East anyway and if they'll be
there with a copy of enlightenment well
hopefully that Bengal
talk about your upbringing in in Iraq
because I mean you're you're in the
United States and you left Iraq
ultimately after helping American forces
or Americans occupying Iraq but you grew
up in a moderate Muslim household I do I
did so I mean I left Iraq in end of 2009
beginning of 2000
10 I didn't grow up in my family which
is I think there isn't why I've been
motivated to really do the translation
project so I mean my dad's automatic
surgery mom was a lawyer they boasted in
the UK they came back to Iraq to fix the
country which didn't turn out well and I
was born I mean they had sex and I was
born of death and and then so yeah
there's no divinity there unfortunately
I thought there was but but 23andme
prove me wrong
so I grew up I mean I I was born 1991 so
just just the right after the Gulf War
and when the sanctions were happening
but because I was a grew up in an
educated family that very I would say
they're liberal even by European
standards like the way I grew up like my
dad gives me a book and we discuss it
every Thursday when we go chicken and
here's a play-doh and here's Karl Marx
and here is Hayek and let's discuss
ideas about freedom and human rights and
all of that so and the goal from him was
like he wanted to make his son to be
critical thinker is like he said he was
I mean he's still a practicing Muslim of
some sort and he is like I want you to
think for yourself that's really the
goal if you want to be a Muslim be
honest Muslim and be comfortable with it
or don't so I grew up in this
environment but there was a clash of
civilization inside the civilization
right so this is the house I grew up in
and then the moment I go outside that
that house then I am exposed to I mean
especially post Iraq war in 2003 and
which al-qaeda took over my neighborhood
I mean they're almost took over my
neighborhood like I wake up every
morning and there's dead bodies on the
streets and beheadings and barbers
getting killed and all of that so there
was I mean I had my own liberal circle
in Iraq so that's actually kind of
maintain maintain my sanity in the same
extent but the Iraq became a war zone
and especially the neighborhood I grew
up in became like the clash between what
used to be called al-qaeda now Isis and
Al made the army and kind of the Shia
militias and they all meet up in my
neighborhood because we grew up in a
kind of like Central West Baghdad
knowing English from a young age I was
able to be exposed to many of these
ideas because I am able to language but
most people don't have that privilege
let's say so say yes there's been like
I'm like knowing that many people are
exposed to a lot of nonsense really
motivates me to kind of correct that the
number of books that are translated into
Arabic every year faster this is a
disaster it's I mean the latest report
we have from the UN even though it's all
that I'm trying to update and also MIT
Media Lab doing some of that is that
there are more books translated to
Spanish in one year than Arabic in 1,000
years and even add to that even
something as accessible as the Wikipedia
Arabic is rated one of the lowest in
terms of articles so there is a
knowledge deficit and there's a
knowledge deficit about what values that
really make society grow that that like
enlightenment and individual Rison and
separation of powers most people don't
know these ideas and it's no surprise
that like when America came in to win
the hearts and minds that didn't work
out well we recently marked the 17th
anniversary of the 9/11 attacks yeah
what is the best way that the United
States can contribute to a lessening of
Islamic terrorism that doesn't you know
actually end up causing more problems or
causing as many problems as it might try
to solve can I pitch my organization now
yeah
this constant warfare and stuff another
I don't believe that there are some
needs for Wars and once in a while but I
think that really engaging with the
Muslim world on and really being on the
right side of history in terms of
supporting the people who hold these
ideas and spreading these ideas I think
I think that this is it's a long-term
goal to make people adhere to some of
these values that I think makes them
progress but I don't think there is an
alternative to that I think that soft
power and more engagement in education
and really approaching the Muslim world
not as an enemy but as as a world that
that we can help and we can learn from
what are the things that we can learn
from well I mean there are some elements
within Middle Eastern societies that I
think are good I mean we value family we
value
it's a land of civilization I mean where
I come from I mean obviously Iraq is a
modern state but I was born in Babylon
and that's a and also the Egypt they
have there also history with Egyptian so
there's there's a lot to learn from the
Middle East it's a region filled with
the Cardinal civilization and and also
one day in once upon a time which is
when the House of Wisdom was there and
all of that this was in an area which
was very developed in science and
progress and good values that well
Europe at the time was actually living
in some sort of Dark Ages so so I think
that it can be done again and if that
region of the world succeeds and becomes
better than it is right now it's good
for all of us I mean number one is good
for the people who live there there's
good for the women who are constantly
being persecuted for not wearing a
headscarf in Tehran so it's good for the
people there to follow let's say the the
projectory of human rights and and and
separation of powers individual rights
and it's also I mean if something that
9/11 has taught us I think is that the
Middle East is the opposite of Las Vegas
what happens in the Middle East doesn't
stay in the Middle East you have to be
engaged and you know that violence is
not the solution so support the more the
war of ideas and really getting and also
we have to defend these values at home
here as well are you optimistic about
the near future
I mean Europe is worrying me quite a lot
I think America has a strong foundation
that is not gonna turn crazy and also
because America is not based on a nation
not nation state but nationalistic
identity which is tied to race which is
kind of different than Europe Europe has
a history there is a French and there's
the Germans and there's all of that and
what's happening there especially with
the migration also the former immigrants
who come from the Muslim world of Arab
world is that you have people who have
very strong identity and you have people
who also have that strong energy and
immediately clash and and Europe was a
birthplace for many bad ideas regarding
to race and others and and this I'd even
though they had a phase of kind of the
European Union and peace and all of that
but this ideas can emerge again so I'm
very worried about the future of Europe
I think that it might be
possible that a recreation of some sort
of a far-right movement that really
makes its way to power is possible we
can see it in some countries I think
Hungary is one of them and and I think
Denmark they lost the elections they're
the kind of the party the centrist party
so yeah I am very I mean merrily upon in
France and I mean thank goodness we got
the centrist guy but but the fact that
she was able to gain that much support
is a problem and also I mean will comes
to the states I mean we've got you get
the travel bans and you get the kind of
the anti-muslim rhetoric on one side and
then you have kind of the constant
victimization I do the politics that are
played by the other side to the way that
it's getting more and more difficult to
have a conversation it's really anyone's
conversation and I always mentioned that
like if we look at humans humans are
complicated and they can be oppressed
and they'd be oppressors at the same
time and somebody can be facing an
anti-muslim bigotry which I'm against
but this person can also kill his
daughter for having a boyfriend these
two things do not contradict each other
so so trying to just put Muslims on one
hand as oppressed oppressor etc you're
not really and you're not looking at
humans and Muslims as a human beings and
we have to look as muscles as human
beings that try to understand the
nuances of their religion and their
personality and the culture they come
from and till we get that there we're
going to consider it constantly be part
of this rhetoric of the far right and
the far left we've been talking with
faisal saeed al Matar he's the head of
ideas Beyond Borders for reason I'm
Nicholas bee